nous allons venir maintenant un sujet
beaucoup plus féminin mais qui concerne
aussi les hommes bien sûr il s'agit de
la coiffure vous l'avais pensé tout à
l'heure vous l'avez compris tout à
l'heure entendant jean louis david s'est
en effet l'époque où on se prépare à
partir en vacances où il faut changer de
coiffure pour pouvoir se baigner plus
facilement pour pouvoir faire du sport
etc etc
c'est en général l'époque à laquelle les
coiffeurs conseil de raccourcir les
cheveux et de les couper d'une manière
abondante d'aller voir d'ailleurs nous
avons demandé à trois de nos
téléspectatrices de se prêter à cette
coupe de cheveux chez jean-louis david
et vous allez être assez surpris parce
que on enlève beaucoup beaucoup de
cheveux j'ai envie de vue beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de vent mais on en
garde beaucoup derrière vous allez voir
nous avons pris donc le cas de trois
prothèses créatrice vous voyez l on l'a
c'est un cavalier à cheveux très longs
et il va falloir le transformer et nous
allons couper carrément devant de façon
à ce qu'elle ait autour du visage un
cheveu qui encadrent - le visage mais il
faut garder aussi beaucoup de féminité
et pour cela il faut naturellement
garder une nuque qui se plus longue
c'est enfin je pense que tout l'actu
liste qui réside dans le fait que les
cheveux dans le t'être excessivement
léger que l'on n'a plus besoin de la khl
a plus besoin de faire de mise en plis
et cela est une chose très importante
alors forcément quand on voit des grands
coups de ciseaux comme ça on est un peu
au fisc et parce qu'on pense que ne va
plus rien rester mais là il ce n'est
qu'un problème de dégrader et le cheveu
est temps
donc coupé en mesh qui se superposent
les unes sur les autres ont donné une
souplesse et un naturel qui sera
beaucoup plus facile vous voyez le
visage est entouré et en même temps
derrière il y a la possibilité de passer
la main mais je crois que c'est quelque
chose toujours très importante
finie l'époque des petits garçons mais
on doit quand même je crois que c'est
important pour cet été aller sur la
plage avec des cheveux qui vous libère
totalement des contraintes
là c'est un autre cas où on a on a des
cheveux excessivement fond c'est ce qui
était assez difficile
nous avons essayé plusieurs coiffure
devant une glace on sent très bien
content on a essayé une raie sur le côté
et on voit de suite que c'est très sûr
le côté parce que très mauvais ça lui va
très mal ce s'accentue le bas du visage
on voit ici une raie au milieu et
mondiaux se sont encore bien moins
concluants alors il ya une troisième
solution c'est essayer de mettre les
cheveux en arrière et de les coupés très
courts sur le bossu mais là aussi on
garde une nuque qui est une ligue
féminine de façon à éviter tout ce qui
peut être dur il faut essayer de créer
un flou autour d'un visage c'est ce
qu'il a dit ou si le plus là une grande
mèche qui tombe là on coupe on coupe ah
oui ça y est on coud
alors forcément pu appeler la cliente
parce qu'un peu dire la patiente à ce
moment-là moment c'est difficile mais
ensuite je crois que comme ce n'est pas
une mode de ligne c'est une mode
d'esprit il est plus facile de vivre
avec un cheveu qui sont cheveux libres
autour du visage qu'un cheveu qu'il soit
un quart quand on dégrade le devant de
façon de jeu à ce que je veux sur les
jets et on ne fait pas de mise en plis
ensuite on sèche au séchoir à main on
la ligne donnée par la coupe voyez à ce
genre à main en lice en arrière c'est
très simple on va boucler avec un fer à
friser face au sochaux successivement
naturel et sans après une grande
transformation qui s'est fait dans la
coiffure ces derniers temps il y a
surtout le fait que la construction même
des coiffures est totalement différente
et les volumes sont en train de se
transformer énormément ce qui permet
renouvelle landes la façon dont on
procède pour arriver à un résultat
alors là naturellement on peut mettre la
main dans ses cheveux sur nos envies on
n'est pas absolument tenu de d'éviter
tout contact de la coiffure avec où les
mains
un chapeau on peut très bien mettre ce
qu'on vous voyez voir un visage qui est
beaucoup plus libéré c'est beaucoup
moins dure malgré malgré une couleur qui
étreint france est renforcée pour
l'époque certainement
et on voit un visage qui est beaucoup
plus naturelle là aussi alors là c'est
le troisième cas on avait on a une nuque
très courte départ c'était très embêtant
parce que ça
si quand les nuques sont très courtes ça
empêche celui mal de donner un effet
actually sts
alors on a cherché un moment pour faire
la trouver je pense système qui étaient
ces biens du fait que vous voyez quand
ses cheveux sont mouillés autour de son
visage on sent que les volumes qu'elle
avait avant été démolies ou
disproportionnée et on retrouve beaucoup
plus de jeu laisse dès qu'il y à
beaucoup moins de matière autour du
visage dès que cheveux le visage -
enfance et derrière les cheveux quand tu
as le mastering coupe d'un système de
coupe c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas de
définition de ligne 7
une mode d'idées plutôt d'esprit ou
qu'une mode où il y un con struction
énorme l'envoyait là aussi ça a été fait
avec un brushing coup de faire par
dessus les volumes sont totalement
transformé enfin pour moi elle est
énormément actualiser la reprit le
jeunesse qu'elle méritait
[Musique]